Sirens Blair across Southern Israel
overnight as Rockets from Gaza streak
across the sky Palestinian militants
have fired more than 500 in the past
four days Israel has intercepted many
but not all yesterday one rocket hit an
apartment building killing an Israeli
man and wounding five others in Gaza the
suffering also continues Israel hit
roughly 150 targets Palestinian
officials say more than 30 people have
been killed including at least 10
civilians in the current fighting this
father carries the lifeless body of his
ten-year-old daughter one of the
youngest victims parents there worry for
their children the worst fighting in
months escalated after Israel targeted
key commanders of Islamic Jihad in Gaza
Israel's prime minister warned his
country will kill whoever threatens it
Egyptian mediators are now working for a
ceasefire